welcome back everyone i do want to do a
video on the things that were correct
and incorrect and basically go through
the video that i made on uh the leaks
from my time to shine hello uh if you
haven't seen it go watch it or just
stick around for this one i'm going to
literally go piece by piece uh on that
video and
pretty much tell you which ended up
being correct and which didn't let's get
started
and here we go we have wanda will fight
charles xavier who is leading the
multiversal illuminati against her
obviously true i personally thought that
the illuminati was gonna have a bigger
role but ultimately uh we did not see
that the events of the movie will take
place two years after one division where
we will see strange face a difficult
choice between ending juana's life to
save the multiverse or abiding by his
hippocratic oath and dooming all of
reality
i think we pretty much
saw this right after no way home so i
don't necessarily think it was two years
i don't
i'm maybe wrong but i don't think it was
two years it was definitely a little
shorter than that uh the pre-visit shots
are probably legit these are the ones we
saw of doctor strange and the ultron
bots uh the charles xavier ones uh
obviously legitimate uh tom cruise was
in talks at one point to appear as tony
not true at least we didn't see it in
the movie there was again the rumors
that he was supposed to come out at
least in the uh post-credits scene
during juana's battle with xavier she is
wearing black pants and a white shirt
covered in blood which is why i think
the previz is legit the blood is from
other members of the illuminati
everything is true but it wasn't the
blood of the illuminati it was nothing
more than apparently the inside oil and
whatnot of the old trump bots
xavier has a hovered share and a small
but significant role they could easily
hide it in the marketing very true that
was huge in the super bowl
uh
the trailer that we got
wanda is not wearing the scarlet witch
outfit because this isn't actually our
wanda not her body anyway wanda from the
illuminati universe looks just like our
wand of face wise
obviously true we saw this
and uh it was consider it was called
dreamwalking as you guys know uh xavier
fights wanda inside her mind evan peters
is not in the movie 100 correct captain
carter won't die
100 wrong when we saw her get chopped
and a half
wanda is the main villain schuma which
is originally supposed to be schuma but
they changed it to gargantuas only uh or
at least the name-wise only has a small
role as a demon wanda summons to bring
chavez to her 100 correct aside from the
shuma part the darkholds is the reason
it's corrupting wanda's mind with the
idea of doing whatever it takes to get
her kids back
it makes her think they need help and
are in danger somewhere in the
multiverse
the first part is correct uh the second
part is not she does not think they're
in danger she is merely trying to get to
them i think originally that was a
thought after one vision if you guys
remember they were analyzing like they
sound like they needed help
wanda is trying to reach them but can
only use natural projection to travel
the multiverse and she needs to make it
so her whole body could go through to
get to her kids the solution is chavez
who can create portals wanda uses the
darkhold to summon demons to bring
chavez to her but the demons destroy
everything in their way including
chavez's reality chavez gets to the mcu
and seeks help and gets to strange who's
attending palmer's wedding at the time
and then shuma gets there and is
attacking new york uh the part about
destroying her reality is not
necessarily true and i think in terms of
we only saw two of them correct uh
stranger beats schumann gargantos and
talks to chavez after the strange goes
after that strange goes to wanda and
they have a fight strange tries to bring
her back to her senses but there's no
use
true i want to say that's about 100
percent true awana gets to the camartage
and blow the place up looking for chavez
uh strange and chavez run into other
realities escaping wanda they go through
a lot of crazy places till they get to a
mortal variant who's the master of the
mystic arts in his universe technically
true
uh he tricks them and brings them to the
illuminati
uh a police keeping force of the
multiverse led by charles xavier they
put strange and chavez in prison
uh to get to uh them wanda takes over
the body of this universe's wanda who's
just a normal housewife with her kids
completely true she uses her body to
kill some of the illuminati and get
chavez out but before she can do that
xavier enters her mind and tries to free
her mind from the mcu wanda he's also
trying to reach mcuanda and help her
come to her senses when wanda finally
gets to her kids she realizes they will
never they were never in any danger and
were living happily with another
wanderer in that universe on a farm the
kids want their real mother back and
fear this wanda this breaks wanda and
she disappears
but not before she does the same thing
she did in one division but this time to
the whole multiverse not necessarily
true um at least that whole last part uh
definitely didn't do anything to the
whole multiverse she just ended up
destroying the dark old as we saw
stranger chavez get back to the mcu but
the multiverse is more broken than ever
not true
i don't think we saw anything
necessarily broken when they came back
to the mcu uh although it technically is
correct because a lot of stuff is going
on but that we have i'm guessing what
wanda did and will get her kids to the
mcu and they'll be older
her sadness and madness is the cause of
the wave slash blast of energy similar
to wanda vision not sure if the
multiverse gets hexed but something
happens to it and it's not good
not necessarily true
um this it's a wanda and strange movie
very true
i'm just a hint of american chavez
mcu mordo is only seen for five minutes
trying to hunt wanda before she kills
him not true i was hoping we saw that
but we did not see that at the beginning
uh mcu palmer only has a small role
while illuminati palmer is the main one
we see
100 correct
loki was not in the version i heard but
reshoots might have changed it
true or at least it was true in the
sense that he wasn't there uh magic is
not in the movie
that character was not in the movie uh
monica is a variant well i think it was
technically maria rambo correct
uh rintra is on strange and wong's team
to help find want to fight wanda uh that
was uh true technically i didn't we'd
see as much as of him that i thought we
were mordo from the illuminati verse is
also a bad guy who betrays the
illuminati for wanda uh he will stick
around after the movie
not true
he did not betray the illuminati
um
and there are six members of the
illuminati true
uh mcu will be named six or six one six
hundred percent true
uh strange gets a comic accurate suit at
one point
not true right i don't know i don't
think we ever saw that uh darkhold
castle exists obviously
ending uh gives a house of m vibes
not true technically i don't know what
remnants of that really sort of gave
house of m vibes xavier will be a
variant from the x-men films ultron
drones arrest strange
yes
very true strange asking wanda to help
him is followed by him realizing she's
the one sending demons from the
multiverse into the mcu and they fight
uh
yeah pretty much true right i mean
there's there's no way about it that's
exactly what happens supreme strange
isn't the villain and his role isn't
even that big
wanda and mordovarian are the main
villains
i don't know if
mordo variant was technically a huge
villain but i mean he's pretty much one
that poisoned them and put them in
prison uh mr fantastic is one of the
illuminati members they added more
members after reshoots
true i'm not sure which the original
members were but we do have mr fantastic
obviously uh there are illuminati
members uh and there are helpers palmer
variant some other x-men and ultron
drones controlled by stark variant are
helpers well i don't know we didn't get
any x-men uh ultron drones
um no actual mention of stark we have
wanda is full of villainous and ends up
winning i'm not sure but she might do a
reverse no more mutants and bring them
instead of getting rid of them not true
that would have been great but no we did
not see that they had ideas for many
characters cameo not sure how many
actually made it in
not sure how many black bolt was an idea
early on not sure if he's in the film
and he was
uh thank you so much everyone that stuck
around uh this is just nice to sort of
go back and see what was true and what
was not a big majority was definitely
someone that knows uh the ends
of
marvel as a whole so let me know what
you guys think down below what would you
have liked to see from these specific um
plot leaks that didn't come true uh
there was a few of them in there that i
would have left to see maybe an x-men or
two maybe a
reverse no more mutants kind of thing
would have been fantastic and there's my
old logo
thank you so much please subscribe if
you haven't and i'll see you guys soon
thanks